This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences
essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the health and dependents. Construise a career enriching to service
of the community francophone of all the country. Don't the quality in French, it's possible
with the City. Visit Collage LaC. .A. today, An initiative of the Consortium National
of Formation in Health Supposed by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the woman that saw the murder
take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey
toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS.
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Chichariot-O-Nand-es,
and listen to learning to be human. on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akela Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 is about both of those things. As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority black city, in which there were more homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Speg and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode before we get. into it, I want to remind you all that this episode of the podcast and so many others are now available on Netflix, not just in the US, not just in Canada, but in the UK, in Australia, in Germany, in Malaysia, in South Africa, just to name a few. So if you are a fan of watching a podcast as you listen to it, this is your chance. You can go and watch a video episode of the podcast right now, right this very second just by searching the psychology of your 20s on your Netflix app. Go ahead, give it a go, see what all the fuss is about, and I sincerely hope that you enjoy it. Today, we are
talking about one of the greatest freedoms I think we can experience as human beings, realizing that not everyone will like you and simply no longer caring. What a beautiful thing. I truly think the second chapter of life begins when you come to understand that you cannot be liked by everyone. And truly, that is in fact a privilege. It is a privilege for that to be the case. Like most of us, I think I grew up believing that there was a direct correlation between my happiness and the more people who liked me. The more people who found me pleasant, enjoyable, interesting, fun to be around,
the more fulfilled I would be. all of these like compulsions emerge from that belief system that probably and definitely have made me actually a lot less happy. They've probably also made me a worse friend. I think they've made me a worse daughter, sister, person. The more you experience life, and again, I'm still really at the beginning like most of you are, but I think slowly the more you experience life, the more you realize that trying to force yourself into a version that everyone finds pleasing is actually going to create so much more dissatisfaction and self alienation than if you just truly accepted that some people aren't going to like you. And that's just that. So that is what I want to dissect today.
Why we find ourselves begging for the approval of others, even when we know it's not in our best interests, what you lose when you do so and what you gain when you decide and in fact, practice and rehearse this idea and this principle that not everybody has to like you. And finally, I think that that probably means you're doing something, right? Because this might be a controversial take, but I genuinely think that people who are liked by everyone are rather boring. And that is not you. That is certainly not you.
So if you can embrace the power of being disliked and what that means for your identity and what that says about your character, I think that you will become a much more interesting fun and wonderful human being. So that is what we are going to discuss today without further ado. Let's get into it. So to begin with a very simple principle and a very simple understanding, why do we feel the need to be liked so deeply by absolutely everyone when we know that that is in fact probably not going to happen? The most simple explanation is that we are and have always been safest in a group. I know that this explanation has been done a million times over, but when we can rely upon
others around us to support our individual needs, because they like us, because they see us as one of them, because there is reciprocity, we are better primed to survive in the long run and to be fulfilled. There is this evolutionary instinctual drive to return back to the herd for better and for worse, and that has been embedded in us since the very beginning, because the herd, the herd represents a strong system that we can predict, a system where we feel least susceptible to threats, and also the danger emotionally, physically, mentally, of having to go at things alone. So much of our behavior as humans is determined by our desire to attach and our desire to be liked. And anybody who says otherwise, anybody who says they don't care, who says,
as they are completely unaffected by others' opinions are lying, because to feel that way would be to deny the very nature of your humanity and what it means to be human. We know this is a fundamental drive. We know the desire to be liked as a fundamental drive, because we feel it when it's not met. Specifically, when we don't feel accepted, we feel lonely. And loneliness sits parallel to things like hunger and thirst and tiredness. It is an emotion, yes, but it is, it is. It is, it. It is, it. It is, is also a biological sign that something we need for functioning, in this case, social acceptance, is not being met. I'm sure you've all heard this before, but loneliness, rejection, not feeling socially included, affects your body in ways, in almost identical ways to true physical, tangible pain.
We have to remember, pain is not felt in the body it is felt in the mind. When you scrape your knee, the part of you that goes, ouch, that hurts, let's deal with that, is not actually your knee. It is your brain that's interpreting and feeling the sensation that is arriving from the neurons in your knee. Those same internal systems that are happening in your mind are equally activated by things like loneliness, meaning that not feeling liked is literally the equivalent of being physically wounded. Your brain cannot tell the difference. The feelings you are having, they're not dramatic.
The desire to be liked for everybody is not dramatic. It is backed by science. This is why we develop people-pleasing tendencies and why we try and chameleon ourselves for everyone we meet or everybody we engage with. We are essentially trying to ensure that no matter what, we won't be left out in the cold. If we are for everyone,
there will never be, there will be no shortage of people who will like us, who will be our friend, who will support us, who will think of us. And that feels like insurance, because if the people we are currently aligned with suddenly drop us, the fact that we are liked by everybody, the fact that we have these backups feels significant and feels safe and reduces the likelihood in our mind of being ostracized. What's also interesting is, that our tendency to worry about what other people think is also partly because we actually overestimate how much other people think about us. And we overestimate that because centering other people's opinions more strongly allows us to preempt again this deep
social threat of being rejected. Now, this phenomena of believing that everybody at all times is thinking only about you, has a name, it's a name we've mentioned on the podcast before, it's called The Spotlight Effect. Essentially, our mind believes there is this big, giant light shining down on everything that we're doing. Everything that we are doing wrong, everything that we're doing right, every floor, we can't help but overvalue our role in other people's lives and think of ourselves as more significant.
You know, we imagine, again, this spotlight following us around everywhere, bringing attention to everything we'd rather conceal. The reason being, the reason why we have this effect, is that because we are the main character, right? In our own lives, the universe revolves around us. And therefore, when we attempt to slip into the minds of others to evaluate how they're seeing us, we think they must be seeing us as we see ourselves, which is at the center of everything. All our floors laid out, all of our mistakes clear to everyone as they are to us. We give them the sight that we have over ourselves. And this obviously creates a weird panic.
You know, researchers have found and have examined that the spotlight effect is one of the main things that triggers obsessive self-monitoring and self-policing as a reaction to this heightened sense of insecurity that everybody must know the big secrets about us and everybody must be thinking about us. The other thing that researchers reveal is that the spotlight effect, again, is actually real only for us. Nobody is thinking about you that much. There have been so many studies that show I think it's like 90% of people's daily thoughts are about themselves. And yet rationally, we can't see through that. Let's talk about what we lose when we try to be for everyone. We've kind of spoken about why it is we are so eager to be in every single person's pocket and every single person's group or peripheral vision or in their lives.
What is the cost of this? What does this do to our lives and to our attention spans and to our time? Happy Pride Month, Toronto. Pride is an opportunity for you to create your own space, to celebrate your existence. Iheart Radio is proud to be an official sponsor. of Pride Toronto Festival, and we won't stop. Celebrate Pride. Turn up the love and listen to IHeart Pride Canada.
Your 24-7 radio stream and the only playlist you need for your Toronto Pride celebrations. Pride is so great because it gives a whole bunch of people this visibility that they've never had before. We have a ton to celebrate Toronto. Happy Pride, IHeart Radio. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever.
I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no... anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir.
Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so. People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo.
Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the Devil's Quarry on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear The Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to LaV for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby.
Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
It is part of the surprise to me because their new star is Javier T. Torito Hernandez. Everyone sees me a special. a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Barza? From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where
vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has an order perfect and all is just. Wait me, I'm here to put me going to be able to be able to be connect. The Chicharito. On Javier El Chicharro-Nandes and together with IHA Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It is a carac. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. As long as there's a politics of race in America, there's going to be a politics of remembering the Civil War. To get to school, I had to go down Robert Ely Boulevard. Get to the grocery store, I had to go down Jefferson Davis Parkway. If you're an historian and you leave out half of what the history is, you're not doing your job. I'm Akila Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 goes deep on both of those things. The fights, the politics, the people who won, and my personal campaign to add something to the Kentucky State House that's actually worth the wall space.
We are more than our bodies. We contain essence. We contain spirit. How do you represent that? They are just fueling a fire that is really catching. You'll see what I mean. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever. you get your podcasts. Firstly, the biggest thing that comes from needing to be liked by everybody is that you risk losing a coherent sense of self or any stable core that you may have because you've panned it to everybody else's tastes. If we are constantly becoming an emotional, social,
physical version of ourselves that isn't really us to fit in with what we think others will like, how do we know who we really are if that thing is constantly changing? Being individual requires having strong preferences, right? It requires you to really like some things, but also really dislike other things. It requires you to really care about certain events or situations and not care about other things as much. That means you will naturally, because of those preferences and passions, become aligned or misaligned with certain people who just simply don't think the same way as you. And for some people that misalignment can breed dislike. That dislike, that opposition is often a good thing. It is a sign that you have strong enough feelings and know yourself well enough for somebody with equally strong feelings to be able to identify that you think strongly and to not agree with you. That disagreement and maybe even that dislike if it gets to that level at times can only occur because you had some skin in the game and because you you possessed passion. If you lose that passion, yes, you may gain likeability because you're
suddenly, you know, palatable to everyone, you also lose yourself in the process because you stand for and care for nothing. Being liked by everyone requires a level of compromise and flexibility that again, only somebody who has no stable centre can offer or can do. Don't let that be you. Studies have found as well that although more people may like you, if you pander and desire to be liked by them, their actual level of like and how much they like you, and their level of respect for you is actually lower. So basically what these studies are finding is that you might sit at 50% with everyone, but you never sit at 100% with anyone. You know, there's never going to be somebody who fully is like, I really like that person because you're too neutral for people to have an
opinion about you. Of course, there's definitely exceptions to this. You know, it's only natural that we try and be a different version of ourselves at work, have a good working relationship with our colleagues to make sure that we get the promotion or like we don't ruffle any feathers. We might make the effort to like be liked by somebody if it helps us out socially or even if we want to impress them, like on a first date, with a new friend, with a friend's first date or a new partner. But pick your people, really pick your people and investigate why you feel the need to be different to who you are to be liked. And how long that masquerade and how long that, you know, pretending can actually truly last if this person ends up being integral to your life because eventually a mask,
your mask is going to slip. I think this really segues into the second thing we lose when we are liked by everybody, which is that we never actually find our people. We never find those people who are 100% for us. Forcing a persona that is liked by everyone means that the people who would genuinely like you for who you are cannot find you underneath all this other crap that you've put on top. And again, it's not that you're doing it to be manipulative. Maybe it's you're doing it to survive or because you're quite socially anxious, but it is still a distraction. This fake version of you is still distracting.
You become less honest, less natural, less you, and therefore you aren't actually rewarded with those deep and meaningful relationships. There was a study from 2004 that showed that in the context of romantic relationships, especially, people know when you are being inauthentic. And it becomes a barrier for closeness because true intimacy, we know this, requires
vulnerability and the core foundation, the only way that you can be vulnerable is if you are authentic, otherwise your vulnerability has nothing to draw from. I think we all know this, but the more you hustle for approval, the less at ease you are with yourself and the less at ease other people will be with you because they can sense the tension, they can sense that something untrue is behind the way you speak. They might notice you contradicting yourself in front of a different friend, they might even notice you lying. People, when you, when somebody, you make somebody feel manipulated or as if they're being tricked, they don't want to be, they don't want to be your friend, they don't want to be your friend, they don't want to date
you. And so the friendships that would actually suit us, we don't get access to, and the friendships that we are left with, often with people who are probably doing the exact same thing to us, or they match a specific version of us that we have created and paper mashade for that one specific person, meaning you end up with people that you may not even like and actually have nothing organically in common with. And that in itself can get so boring and tiring. Again, I don't want to tell you to not go out there and make an effort to make friends, but examine why it is that the people we often like the least or who show the most disdain or boredom with us, in some ways seemingly become those we try to impress the most.
Like, why does that happen? I don't know if you've noticed this. It's a real phenomenon. The exclusivity they hold, the approval we feel the need to gain from them becomes intoxicating, psychologically intoxicating, and it becomes this like prize. We're so fixated on that we forget that there are people out there who would love us regardless of who we are or what value we had to them. The best example of this phenomenon or like that stereotype is,
is like the in-group or the in-crowd, like at high school. I feel like every single school had one. Often, much of what made them seem so popular and quite frankly powerful and what made us want to be them is the fact that they got to choose who was and wasn't allowed into their group. They leverage very much unconsciously the psychological power of scarcity. And the fact that their approval and belonging to their group is not, not for everyone. They literally, the reason being friends with these people is so attractive is because you know that not everybody can do it. Literally there have been so many papers on this that show exclusivity and this not everyone can have it feeling drive people to do very
irrational things. That's been examined mostly like in an economic context. So think like Omer's bags, think luxury goods, think trending products, think like Laboubos are a great example of how scarcity drives people to do irrational things. It also applies to relationships. It also applies to our social lives as well. You know, at the same time, just to use that high school example again, I'd also wager that the older you get, the more you realize that you actually don't really respect those people today as an adult,
as much as you thought you did when you were at school. And you realize the embarrassing things you maybe did to impress them when, for what, for what reason? I remember there was this guy I knew at college who for whatever reason, I'm sure he had a reason. He probably did have his reasons, but he didn't like me very much. And he made it very, very, very well known that he was not a fan of me. And it made me feel, I distinctly remember feeling like I was like five years old again. And because of his obvious disdain, like I was constantly then trying to impress him, trying to like prove, you. that he should like me.
And honestly, I can look back at that now and be like, that made me look really pathetic. But also, it made me even more stressed and anxious, which probably only increased, I don't know, increased the severity of the traits that I possessed that he didn't like originally. This kind of brings me to the final cost of trying to be universally liked. It's just plain exhausting. Like, it's just so tiring. The psychological toll of pretending is, like, so enormous. On top of everything else that you are doing right now to just exist, you then have to monitor
like every word, every action, every step you take, and that puts you into a state of chronic hypervigilance, draining your cognitive resources, draining your energy, fragmenting your sense of self, all for somebody who probably doesn't even like you to begin with and doesn't appreciate any of the psychological stuff you're putting yourself through. You pay the cost and they don't even appreciate the reward. That's what's really happening when we try and cater to the people who seem to have the greatest level of dislike for us. Science, the research, of course, you guys know, it backs this up. A study from 2025 investigated whether people-pleasing is linked to poor and mental health. They looked at over 2,000 university students. These university students were
asked to basically rate how, to kind of, yeah, say how much. many approval-seeking thoughts, behaviors, and emotions they probably experienced on a day-to-day basis. And then they also gave them this test that measured their personal well-being. So how happy they were, how fulfilled they were, how at peace they were. I feel like you guys probably know what the results are, but the results, just to make it very obvious, showed that the higher the level of people pleasing, the lower the psychological well-being. And actually, the greater the loneliness, the more emotional distress, the people who were working the hardest to have the most people like them were the loneliest. Participants with strong people-pleasing tendencies also
had the worst mental health profiles overall. And obviously that's a bi-directional relationship, right? But it does show how psychologically harmful it is to be in the state of constantly needing to be light. Being everyone's favorite person doesn't work if you have no time for yourself. And often, we feel so much resentment, exhaustion, frustration, that we don't even get the benefit from belonging anyways because we're so stressed. And eventually, you know, you realize it's pointless because the thing is, someone is always going to dislike you. There's literally nothing you can do about it. You could do everything in the world. You could spend millions of dollars on this person. You could fulfill their greatest wishes. Their ability to like you is just not,
they just can't do it. There's a social framework. that's known as the 25% rule. My friends, Sal and Al, shared this with me when I was doing a live show with them. And it states that basically no matter how kind, charming, talented you are, 25% of people will never be convinced into liking you. And the breakdown is basically like this. There are 25% of people will always like you, have always liked you and always will. They will always be in your team. 25% of people will maybe like you initially, but may change their mind and not like you. 25% of people won't like you initially, but may change their mind and have a different impression. And then there's that 25% of people who, irrespective of what you do,
will not like you for whatever reason. That 25% is a fact of life. They're never going to budge. To expand on this, Bob Sutton, a professor of management science at Stanford, talks about this thing called the 90-10 rule. You should strive to have 90% of people like you and 10% of people not. The fact that 10% of people dislike you, in his words, in his eyes, is literal cause for celebration. That is a sign that you are doing something extremely right because no one dislikes somebody who is a fence sitter. Nobody dislikes somebody who is neutral, doing nothing and without passion. They dislike people. They dislike people who have ambition, desires, and who put themselves out there.
Logic follows. Nobody's going to dislike you if there is not a part of you that it is out there and chasing things. And like really investing in yourself because there's something inherent in that that they dislike. Right? All too often, our preoccupation with needing to convince the 25%, or needing to convince the 10%, as Mr. Bob was saying to us, holds us back. That's what he's saying. He's saying, if you had 100% of people like you, you are not achieving your full potential. When we accept that, like again, this like second door we never knew existed is opened. And suddenly you step into this whole new universe that was running
parallel to the one you were previously in where everything's just a lot easier. It's just a lot easier and you're probably a nicer and kinder and happier person as well. So how do we shift into that universe? How do we shift into that way of being? Well, I'm never going to leave you guys hanging. You know I have my tips. You know, I have my little list of advice, my psychological guide, which I'm going to provide to you after this short break. Pride month, Toronto. Pride is an opportunity for you to create your own space, to celebrate your existence. Iheart Radio is proud to be an official sponsor of Pride Toronto Festival and we won't celebrate pride. Turn up the love and listen to IHeart Pride Canada. Your 24-7 radio stream and the only
playlist you need for your Toronto Pride celebrations. Pride is so great because it gives a whole bunch of people this visibility that they've never had before. We have a ton to celebrate Toronto. Happy Pride. Iheart Radio. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. It was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case?
Yes, sir. Fair to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so. People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo.
Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the devil's quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to LaVa for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most.
most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And it's a ton of exciting because their new star is Javier T. Torito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born.
And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa?
From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends. where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has an order perfect and everything is just.
Wait-in me, I'm going to be able to be able to be able to be connect. The Chicharito. And together with IHA Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary, stay close. It is a carac. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio,
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. June is Black Music Month, And on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are? I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like, so much more to do. Like, Prince, he dropped, like, 30 albums. We dropped, like, five right now.
Like, that's the rate we got to be going. Yep, that's a good attitude. You also hear stories from industry legends and hip-hop pioneers like Fab Five Freddy. I directed whenaz's early videos. Which one? One love. Wow. Yes.
literally filmed in his apartment in Queensbridge. His moms were still up in that apartment. Nans was just beginning to take off. His pops used to live near me in Harlem. His dad introduced him to a whole lot of, you know, conscious stuff, and he made a young prodigy. No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversations.
Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Accepting that people don't like you is basically just accepting, I think, a much deeper truth in life, which is that you can't control everything. And you waste precious time trying, time that you could be using to do side quests to make your visions into reality, to be like, whoever the fuck you want to be. A study from 2018 showed that people who accept difficult mental experiences like these
ones, like that of being disliked, rejected, they actually end up achieving a greater level of psychological health, a greater level of social enlightenment. And they typically have more friends because this acceptance helps them change the narrative around why this is happening to them to be something that is more neutral. Basically, they stop searching for a personal explanation for everybody else's problem with them, and they realize that this is a universal truth of being human. Now, obviously, some of these people probably should do some digging, but we're talking about the people who are falling in that 25, 10% of just like the general populate. There's like some people who don't like them. They've tried to investigate,
and then they've realized enough people like me that it's probably not a me problem, and they've come to accept the fact. Again, we're not talking about people. who have like the majority of people have problems with them and they're like, I'm just more free if I don't think about it. We need some balance here. Itchiro Kashimi wrote the book, The Courage to be disliked. He says, I think this is the perfect way to just to succinctly tie it all up. The courage to be happy needs to include the courage to be disliked. When you gain that courage, your interpersonal relationships suddenly feel so much lighter. So here is how we're going to do it. Here is how we're going to find that acceptance for the thing and this specific thing
we can't control. Firstly, something for you to just think about every now and again, do you like everybody? Do you? Can you honestly say everybody in the world is your favorite person that you could like, can you think of nobody you don't dislike? No. And is that necessarily their problem, that you don't like them? Also, no. This is a weird exercise, but sometimes I think about the people I don't necessarily like, and I force myself to consider something about them that other people would find positive to remind myself that everybody has a redeeming qualities, including myself, including the people I don't like. And that really gives me a lot of freedom and just accepting that, again, sometimes it's not about me and it's not about them.
Secondly, just like you don't have to change your opinion of those people, despite what may be good about them or not, others don't necessarily have to change their opinion of you because we're not owed an explanation for why somebody does or doesn't approve of us. If you seriously want to be liked by everybody, I think the logic follows that you have to like everybody back. And is that something that you're willing to do? Probably not. I also think it's important to keep in mind the cost of being liked by everybody, and that's like the list we've already given, right? The self-alienation, the somewhat counterintuitive truth that being liked but everyone actually means you have fewer
good friendships. The time that you lose, the trust that you lose, especially the time that you spend being obsessive, like, are you willing to pay that cost? Is that worth it to you to spend precious time on earth worrying about those things? Or would you rather invest it in something more fruitful. Thirdly, recognize the way that your fear of being disliked mirrors the things you dislike about yourself and the things that you unconsciously haven't fully accepted yet. Psychologists sometimes refer to this as projection. It's basically a defense mechanism first identified by like Freud in psychodynamic theory where we attribute to others the very traits we feel insecure about within ourselves.
If you're deeply afraid that somebody will find you too much, too quiet, awkward, unlikable, or if you see all those things in them, it's often because on some level, you actually believe that about yourself. Focusing on that root insecurity will remove the need for the approval you crave because you become comfortable with those things maybe being true. Maybe they are true about you. Maybe you are kind of loud or kind of sensitive or maybe not. But whatever the outcome, you're not going to care about it anyways.
That's just part of who you are. Next, I would also say, change the questions you bring to a social situation to be in your favor. Basically, instead of constantly asking, do they like me, do they think I'm cool, do they think I'm attractive, do they think I'm interesting? Be focused on, and I know it's cliche, but like, do you like them? Especially for dating. Like, do you like them? this first really requires interrogating your fears and anxieties a little bit about why their feelings and opinion why does their opinion matter more than yours where did that come from firstly where did that start
that your opinion is lower than possibly a complete stranger and link it back to what frightens you the most about somebody not liking you is it that it reminds you of when you felt left out at school and you never wanted to be in that situation again Are you worried that you'll be lonely or that you'll die alone or that you'll be abandoned because of a past experience that's still showing up in your day-to-day life? Can you think of the time or a time where this wound was first opened? And then can you find a way to possibly imagine being okay if that situation were to occur? If the worst-case scenario of rejection, being ostracized, being hated were to occur,
can you picture yourself being still okay? I think it's important to remind ourselves we are so much more capable and that our terrible feelings and terrible imaginations and hypotheticals never come true in the way we think they will. And you're going to be so much more fulfilled, leaving a social situation, if you have enjoyed yourself rather than if you have constantly curtailed your behavior so that you're enjoyable to others. Because you got to just, it was just easier. It was lighter. You can't feel embarrassed if you don't ask yourself the question of, did I do? anything embarrassing. Like, do you know what I mean? Asking yourself, instead, questions of like,
was I genuine? Did I have my own approval? Am I, am I caring about what other people are saying? Am I being truthful? Am I having fun? Shapes the experience so that you are on the lookout for situations and people and moments that are going to create more of that within you. I think it's also worth remembering, and this is probably the biggest thing of all, people are responsible for their own emotions the way that you are responsible for your own. You don't have to manage their discomfort for them. You don't have to manage their negative feelings, their upsets, their annoyances at you for them. Like those are, you don't have to fix every single negative feeling, especially if it's about you. It becomes your responsibility when they bring it up, when they're
honest with you, not when they're being passive aggressive, not when they're trying to manipulate or shift your mood for their benefit. Like they're adults. They can feel annoyed at you, frustrated at you. They cannot like you. And that actually is none of your business. And also, not your responsibility. They're an adult. They should know by now how to regulate feelings about other people that have nothing
to actually do with that person. A final internal strategy I like to do is also finding a way to separate your worth from your likability. And a very easy way to do this is literally, and a therapist told me about this one, is literally sit down, make a list of all the things that would still be true and would remain true if suddenly the whole world stopped liking you. If the whole world yet tomorrow decided we don't like this person, what anchors you beyond people's opinions? For example, even if the world decided that you were the worst person, you would still be kind to animals,
wouldn't you? You would still be curious about things that you didn't know about. You would still be a creative person regardless of whether people liked you or not. You would still be a good friend. You would still notice the small things. You would still be a great cook. You would still take great care of your body. You would still be a hard worker. You would still think deeply. These things would remain because they're a part of you more than whether somebody likes those parts of you. And the list could go on and on and on. This is basically like, to be fair, it's just a form of positive affirmation. We know from study after study that thinking good things about ourselves is not arrogance, it's self-protection, and it's expansive. Literally, other people's opinions
may impact us and can impact us, obviously, that's why we're talking about it. But only if we let them kind of like breach the gates of our self-esteem. Affirmations about our own likability that becomes self-truths. Like I think of them like God. They're like the lookouts that are able to identify somebody else's negative thoughts about us before they reach the gates and are able to discard and get rid of them and realize like those thoughts aren't, that's not one of ours. That shouldn't be here because our thoughts and our belief in our self is stronger. So this, this is an intro guide into how we're going to embrace not being for everybody. And I sincerely hope that you do as early as possible.
And listen, like, I'm still figuring it out and I still get really upset anytime I hear a mutual friend or, you know, a friend of a friend doesn't like me. Had that happened the other day and I was, I lost sleep over it. I still at times panicked to people. I shouldn't. I get consumed by me in comment. But I think compared to where I was five years ago, I'm worlds apart from that. And I'm just excited, like genuinely excited for more and more freedom to come with choosing
whose opinions of me I get to care about and choosing who I get to be for. Like, genuinely, I don't know if this is something that other people are going through, but the older I get, the more excited I am to be one of the women that I see in their 50s and 60s and 70s who just like give zero fox who say like what they want, wear what they want, eat what they want, do what they want. Those women to me seem like some of the happiest people alive. And I'm sure there's some research that's probably going to confirm that they are. And they also seem to have as well, like the most profound relationships, the most profound
friendships, the most profound creativity, because, you know, along the way through trial and error, it seems as if they've learned what we are actively learning now, which is that being for everybody robs you of something you actually probably want more from life, which is to be authentic and to be happy. Not being for everybody gifts that back to you, gifts that self-approved, back to you so that you can live freely. And that's something that I'm just really excited for. I can't wait to give less and less and less fucks about other people's opinions. And I can't wait for that to be a testament that I'm probably doing something very, very right
with my life, as so many of these, so much of this research has shown us, not being liked by everybody is a litmus test and is the biggest sign that you're probably living life the way that it should be lived. So that is all we have time for today. I want to thank our researcher, Lucy Davidson, for her help with this episode. Make sure, oh my God, are you guys ready? My big list. Make sure you are following us on Instagram.
Make sure that you have watched a Netflix episode. What's next? Substack. You can send me a DM. You can leave a comment down below. You can send this episode to a friend. There is so much that you can do. And honestly, oh, you can buy my book.
I forgot about that one. All the links are in the description, of course. But please, if you are listening on Spotify, and you are in any of those. countries I mentioned at the beginning, go and check us out on Netflix, just so you can get a sense of the vibe. If you have no idea what I look like as well, because I know some of you don't, now's your opportunity. Off you go, go check it out. As we always end the episode with, be safe, be kind, especially when it comes to social approval, be gentle with yourself, and we will talk very, very soon.
There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It's scary. It's scary. the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence.
Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby is presented by CV. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships,
emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tornandez, and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is. a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is,
getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akela Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 is about both of those things. As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority black city in which there were more homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Every family has its secrets.
But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation. I felt it was what I had to do. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human.
Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.